okay oh hello there i'm abby sharp
welcome to another edition of toilet
talk where i share my best tips on
achieving the healthiest gut our
question today comes from my friend
Peggy hi Abby I'm a few weeks pregnant
and after reading the mommy message
boards I've noticed that many moms have
cut out gluten during their pregnancy
apparently it may reduce baby's risk of
developing celiac disease well my
husband has celiac disease and I would
hate for my baby to have to go through
all that discomfort so does this diet
change actually lessen their chances are
there really any benefits of going
gluten-free during my pregnancy
sincerely pregnant Peggy thanks for your
letter Peggy so a gluten free diet has
been used for a variety of health
conditions so it was only a matter of
time before researchers started to
investigate whether or not going gluten
free during your pregnancy can actually
reduce the risk of baby developing
celiac disease so recently we've seen a
lot of people going gluten-free for
weight loss reasons however for people
with celiac disease a gluten-free diet
is imperative for preventing the risk of
a lot of different health conditions and
of course
total malnutrition so let's take a look
at whether or not going gluten-free
during pregnancy has any benefits for
mom and Vague recently Danish scientists
want to test mice to see if having a
gluten free pregnancy would reduce the
risk of celiac disease in their
offspring what they found was over all
the mice that were born to moms that had
a gluten free pregnancy had a lower risk
of developing celiac disease compared to
the mice whose mom consumed gluten so
this is a great start but let's not get
carried away here because we know that
this was only carried out on mice so
we've got a long way to go when it comes
to figuring out whether or not this is a
modifiable risk factor when we also know
that celiac has a really strong
hereditary component let's look at the
research on humans a 2015 study looked
at gluten intake during late pregnancy
and found no link between gluten intake
and the risk of celiac disease in their
baby what's important to note is that
this study was observational so
researchers couldn't modify different
factors that may have
results so we don't have a really strong
verdict when it comes to whether or not
going gluten-free during pregnancy has
an impact on celiac disease but there's
some other interesting trials going on
let's talk about those there is some new
research that suggests that going
gluten-free during pregnancy may reduce
the risk of type 1 diabetes and babies
however again these are based on mice
trials so don't go cutting out gluten
just yet
aside from moms intake of gluten during
pregnancy there are other factors that
may impact babies risk of celiac disease
including antibiotics vitamin D and iron
so we know that antibiotics can wreak
havoc on our gut health so researchers
want to know whether or not this effect
would be strong enough to increase the
risk of celiac disease in our babies the
good news is that even though
antibiotics may have an impact on babies
gut health it does not seem to be a
strong enough effect that would increase
the risk of Sling as serious as celiac
disease so if you need to take
antibiotics during your pregnancy be
sure that you do so what about iron
supplements a lot of us mamas are told
that we need to up our iron during
pregnancy well one study found that
mothers who took iron supplements during
their pregnancy had an increased risk of
their baby's developing celiac disease
but don't freak out the association was
not strong enough to be drawing any
conclusive claims recently there's been
a lot of interest in the research
community when it comes to vitamin D
supplementation and the risk of disease
and what they found was moms who
supplemented with vitamin D during their
pregnancies may have had a reduced risk
of type 1 diabetes and a mess in their
offspring however when it came to celiac
disease the results were underwhelming
and very limited so as a dietitian I'm
often asked when is the best time to
introduce gluten to my baby's diet in
order to reduce the risk of celiac
disease but what's unclear is whether or
not the exposure to gluten had a
protective effect at their lives or if
it just delayed the onset of their
diagnosis of celiac disease this is
because the researchers only followed
the babies for the first two years of
life so we need some more long-term
studies before we can make conclusive
claims while this is helpful news other
research has found that the timing of
gluten introduction has had no impact on
the risk of celiac disease in babies
having said that they did concur with
the other research suggesting that the
introduction of large amounts of gluten
may increase the risk while Peggy I hope
this information has given you a bit of
clarity
when it comes to going gluten-free
junior pregnancy and the risk of celiac
disease in your baby if you have celiac
disease then of course be sure you're
keeping a gluten-free diet for both the
health of you and your baby however if
you don't have celiac disease or gluten
intolerance I really don't see a strong
association in the literature to support
the idea of you going gluten-free if you
decide to cut out gluten be sure to
always be in the care of your doctor or
a registered dietician because cutting
out major food groups can have
implications of your baby's health and
nutrition so guys I hope you enjoyed
this video if you did be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
with some of your burning toilet talk
questions subscribe to the channel and
I'll see you next time on Abbey's
kitchen bye
[Music]